bonsoir jean luc addor merci d'être avec
son direct sur arte france la suisse
at-elle eu raison pour vous de claquer
la porte à l'union européenne
c'est qu'il apporte c'est bon on vit
apparemment la fin de négocier n'était
pas vraiment parce que c'était plutôt un
diktat
on nous présentait depuis depuis un
moment
le résultat de ces pseudo négociation
comme quelque chose de non négociable et
puis nous on a regardé un petit peu ce
qui s'est passé avec la grande bretagne
ça nous a encouragés à penser qu'on peut
survivre contrairement à ce qu'on essaie
de nous faire croire quand on quand on
essaye de négocier d'égal à égal avec
l'union européenne
c'est très exactement ce qui s'est passé
et puis je salue le courage du concept
du conseil fédéral qui a su défendre
l'indépendance de la suisse fasse
finalement la bureaucratie de bruxelles
et puis je pense que ça va donner lieu à
ça va donner un nouvel élan à de vraies
négociations entre partenaires
et puis pas entre le maître et son
vassal de vraies négociations enfin tout
de même ça fait quand même sept ans que
ça dure cette affaire de pourparlers on
les appelle comme on veut
pourquoi aussi longtemps pour finir par
capoter en général on sait qu'on va
passer à entendre un petit peu en amont
quand même pour moi ce que je pense
c'est que depuis trop longtemps depuis
pendant toutes ces années on a négocié
du côté suisse avec une forme d'esprit
de soumission et puis ça s'est terminé
ça pour moi c'est la leçon à tirer
et puis maintenant ce qui semble
souffler du côté du conseil fédéral
c'est un esprit d'indépendance
et ça franchement je salue parce que
encore une fois on a en a de l'espoir
qui est venu de grande-bretagne
et puis aussi pour les pour les peuples
européens pour les états européens qui
qui veulent conserver un semblant de
souveraineté je pense que c'est un
espoir mais c'est un espoir d'abord pour
nous au suisse parce que nous tenons à
conserver notre démocratie directe à ce
que nos citoyens puissent continuer à
donner leur avis sur des questions
importantes sans être sans être soumis à
des diktats européen qui pourrait jamais
remettre en cause sans être soumis à des
verdicts d'une juridiction européenne à
laquelle on peut très très marginalement
participer et voilà donc c'est c'est un
signe fort d'indépendance et est un
encouragement conseil fédéral a
renégocié encore une fois des galas il y
avait deux grandes craintes on lire les
analyses grande crainte des suisses
d'une part la protection des salaires
qu'il faut bien le dire sont plus élevés
que dans le reste de l'union européenne
la plupart du temps et la crise
migratoire également qui semble-t-il ont
échaudé les amis suisses on commence par
cette dernière
la suisse avait peur de quoi
concrètement de voir débouler sur son
sol les migrants c'est exactement ça
donc nous ne voulons pas nous soumettre
une une politique migratoire l'ipad vous
l'immigration le contrôle de
l'immigration c'est c'est un attribut
très important de la souveraineté la
souveraineté c'est pas juste se sont pas
juste des questions militaires
ce sont des questions économiques il ya
des enjeux économiques dans cet accord
ce sont des enjeux institutionnels il y
en a aussi
et puis ce sont entre autres également
des enjeux en termes de d'immigration
nous tenons dans ce pays à conserver
notre liberté de manom notre
souveraineté en matière migratoire la
question des salaires également qui je
le disais sont plus élevés en suisse que
dans le reste de l'europe vous avez peur
que d'appartenir en tout cas d'avoir un
partenariat très privilégié à l'europe
me fasse perdre 7 entre guillemets
avantage
alors c'est évident qu'un un des
facteurs qui a puissamment contribué
notamment dans les partis politiques de
gauche dans les milieux syndicaux qui a
puissamment contribué à a coulé cet
accord c'est évidemment la crainte
légitime parce que ce sont des évidences
la crainte que cet accord soit un outil
formidable de tom ping salariale dont
finalement tous les travail ni
travailleurs si un passionnant les
suisses de passeport mais toutes les
personnes qui travaillent en suisse qui
bénéficie de nos conditions salariales
de nos conditions sociales pas ce sont
toutes ces personnes ça fait beaucoup de
monde qui ont vraiment du souci à se
faire
si si on signe un accord en sait
maintenant que ce sera pas le cas si on
6,1 à un accord tel que celui que
l'union européenne cherche à nous
imposer en osant peur et ce qui fait
plaisir c'est que finalement c'est ces
soi disant vous savez quand on est avec
des partenaires on se prétend
partenaires puis quand on travaille avec
avec le chantage avec la peur avec la
menace obtenait ça suffit j'ose dire que
c'est le message que le conseil fédéral
chevaux félicite à 1 a su faire passer à
union européenne qui a le plus à perdre
finalement dans cet échec selon vous à
vous entendre on dirait que vous en
sortez plutôt bien et que c'est à
l'europe de regretter ce manque d'accord
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué les
relations elles vont dans tous les sens
quand on fait là
le bilan de la balance commerciale
finalement on a beaucoup de raisons de
penser que c'est plutôt l'union
européenne qui est bénéficiaire
l'union européenne on est un pays un
pays petit peut-être mais au centre de
l'europe y compris du point de vue des
transports des voies de communication
moi je pense que on doit revenir à de
vraies négociations entre partenaires il
inquiète beaucoup plus gros bien sûr
puis un autre qui est petit mais chacun
a des atouts à jouer
alors maintenant je pense que le message
c'est l'union européenne arrête de
chercher tout le temps à nous faire peur
on arrête de nous faire croire qu'on va
mourir
si on n'accepte pas ces distincts ses
dictats pardon et on se met à table
entre partenaires loyaux
on joue chacun ses atours et je pense
que comme ça on a de bonnes chances
d'arriver passer l'intérêt aussi bien de
l'union européenne que la suisse la
suisse
bien sûr elle est au milieu de l'europe
donc au milieu de l'union européenne
même l inverse est également vrai
l'union européenne les pays qui nous
entourent la france l'allemagne l'italie
l'autriche c'est l'eau c'est aussi leur
intérêt que d'entretenir des relations
correctes avec la suisse puis voyez on a
deux pays fin caucus qui qui cherchent
les pays européens qui cherche à nous
vendre un avion de combat
je ne sais pas s'ils ont envie de le
vendre mais s'ils ont envie je pense que
c'est une bonne idée de se mettre à
table avec la suisse merci à jean luc
addor conseiller national udc suisse
merci